[Music]
thanks for being here Rob I have to say
many times when people are quoting
really funny tweets to me they're by you
you you write real gems thank you yeah
and get them out there and you have
become a social media star and you've
taken your power and used it for good
only good yeah you not long ago you sued
Kim Kardashian tell us about that just
for for 24 million dollars yes when she
really did this you really did it became
a class-action lawsuit once people got
excited and wanted to get on the
bandwagon I did you sue her for how much
again 24 million uh-huh because that's
what she was paid for the dual episode
fake marriage that she did and we all
knew that it was fake when she did it
but we figured she'd at least adhere to
the you know convention of staying
married for 20 minutes but she didn't
she got divorced and I said no so you
wouldn't so you went and you filed
papers and you said I'm suing you for 24
million dollars doing people dot fell in
love with this idea so I immediately
like I just said I was gonna do it I
wrote an open letter to her in a
magazine and then immediately a bunch of
lawyers contacted me and pro bono were
like we this is why we became lawyers so
we were I was like look you can either
stay married which is what I wish for
you I don't hate you Kim Kardashian I
want you to know the joy of marriage I'm
married you're married you know can be
okay if you give it 20 minutes but she
wouldn't and so I had to see work and I
told her I was either gonna give the
money to a charity or to my uncle Rick
who lives in Rhode Island and is a drug
dealer bad person but that's better use
of the money okay you've also become
overnight you became Mitt Romney's
Twitter nemesis how did that happen well
I give him a hard time
well I'm from Massachusetts like you so
I've paid a little more closer attention
to him than than the average American
and he's our governor and he just
fascinates me he's like let's imagine
for example you're a two-liter bottle of
soda
all right I'm speaking in metaphors here
there's the label
I've got a soda he is just like a clear
pitcher and whatever you put in there
you can just see if that's orange juice
you know where that's mayonnaise if
that's what you want to put in the
pitcher and he's so transparent that it
infuriates me if you want to be
president you're sick
Barack Obama is ill if you want to be
president something's wrong with you
okay he has the most virulent strain of
the disease he's like I just want to be
President so bad and so I make fun of
him now and what happened was you you
got a for a while there whenever he
would come out with a message you had as
many or more Twitter followers than he
had and it would cloud his message
because he would come out with with joke
proclamations at the same time as his
real message that is true yeah their
social media companies or whatever would
be would figure out that I had been more
retweeted mentioning him that he would
be when he was like message and I'd be
like hey Mitt Romney and that would be
much more popular hello a politician
that just goes message pretty much what
they do